it's the fastest growing refugee crisis
europe has seen since the second world
war
i have worked in refugee emergencies for
almost 40 years and rarely have i seen
an exodus as rapid as this one
in the first 10 days of the war against
russia 1.5 million people fled ukraine
and the number is expected to reach 4
million
so what happens to these people when
they flee
[Music]
most of those leaving ukraine are women
and children the country has mandated
that male ukrainian citizens aged
between 18 and 60 cannot leave the
country
they've been told to stay and fight in
some cases unaccompanied children have
been left at the border where both
parents have returned home to fight
non-ukrainian nationals are also
considered refugees it's anyone who's
legally living there like foreign
nationals and international students
most of those fleeing are ending up in
neighboring countries including poland
slovakia hungary romania moldova and
belarus
the majority of these have ended up in
poland
an eu member and geographically and
historically close it's an obvious
choice
so how have they been getting there
thousands have fled to lev in ukraine's
west there the border to poland is just
50 miles away and there's a large train
station
many others have been making their way
by car and even on foot
people have been greeting refugees with
food water clothes and toys once they
arrive
next they must be processed poland's
opened eight reception centers where
refugees can stay
[Music]
[Applause]
in romania makeshift refugee camps have
sprung up in places like suret near
ukraine's southwest border
government has urged households and
institutions to accommodate refugees
they'll get
165 pounds a month for an adult and 82
pounds a month for a child
[Music]
people are also arriving in berlin here
community initiatives have popped up
with some even driving to the border to
bring refugees back ukrainians will have
the right to live and work in the eu for
up to three years and the british
government has announced a special visa
system for ukrainians with families in
the uk but not everyone has received the
same welcome some people of color
fleeing ukraine say they face
discrimination at the borders
one man on black payment
india tonight africans
and middle eastern i should leave here
and go to another border which is
romanian
we
in the first seven days one million
refugees fled the country
to compare syria has the highest number
of refugees who fled their country
nearly 5.7 million people have left
since the civil war began in 2011.
2013 saw the fastest rate of people
fleeing even then it took over three
months to reach the milestone of one
million refugees which ukraine hit in a
week
whether this is temporary or permanent
for these people it's an impossible
question to answer what we do when we're
already in a safe poland hungary or
slovak republic we're very thankful for
this hospitality but we have to
understand how we can settle how our
people can earn their living how can
they settle kids go to schools and all
the stuff the normal people already have
covered
while many would like to say they'll
return home it'll all depend on the
situation with russia
the unhcr is planning for up to four
million refugees and the eu expects this
number to rise to seven million
this humanitarian crisis is growing by
the day